you can use Cleo Columbia's online
catalog to find both print and
electronic books Cleo includes items
from all the libraries at Columbia
except law and teachers college use the
drop-down menu on the main library page
to see the online catalogs from those
libraries when you open Cleo either from
the drop-down menu under catalogs or
from the quick search you are taken to
the basic search screen this is a good
place to look for books by title by
author or by subject note the tabs at
the top of the basic search screen these
offer different types of searches such
as guided keyword or course reserves we
won't be talking about those searches in
this tutorial for a basic search the
default is a title search enter the
title of the book or item you're looking
for leaving at initial articles such as
a the or an you can limit to format such
as electronic or video recording from
the drop down menu below the search box
once you have your results you can be
sorted here I'm showing newest first to
see the record click on the title this
shows you the citation which libraries
have this item and whether or not it's
available to be checked out the full
view often gives a summary and list the
table of contents if the clio record
lists the location as offsite you can
click on the word offsite to place an
online request for the book to be
brought back to campus from our off-site
storage facility in Princeton New Jersey
you will get the book within 48 hours of
your request
to search by author use the last name
first name format there may be a cross
reference to another version of the name
click on more info to see the version of
the name used in clio
to search by subject heading you need to
know the exact Library of Congress
heading for your topic if you're not
sure try a keyword search first and then
see how the heading is listed in the
brief or full record for example if I'm
interested in biblical themes in
Shakespeare I might try a keyword on
Shakespeare and Bible clicking on a
relevant title I can see what subject
headings the library of congress is
assigned to this book these headings are
clickable links
you
to find books about an author the
author's name becomes the subject for
example if I want to see books about
Mark Twain and his writings I use Mark
Twain as a subject heading this list
brings up 151 books about Mark Twain
broken down into various categories for
example books about specific works or
more general titles like criticism and
interpretation if you need more help
using clio look at the help screens and
always feel free to ask a librarian for
assistance
you